Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Hoffmann?
Ich bin 34 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 17. Januar 1992.
Frau Hoffmann, was kann ich für Sie tun? Was für Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Also ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich schon seit mehreren Wochen Durchfälle habe.
Durchfälle, ja.
Und ich habe auch Schmerzen im Unterbauch.
Und habe aktuell auch schon Gewicht verloren.
Gewicht verloren, ja.
Wie viel und in welchem Zeitraum?
Also ich habe diese Durchfälle jetzt seit zwei Monaten schon.
Zwei Monate, ja.
Und ich habe bestimmt schon 5 Kilo abgenommen.
Wo genau haben Sie die Schmerzen?
Im Unterbauch.
Unterbauch, ja.
Strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo in Frau Hoffmann?
Nein, sie sind im Unterbauch.
Sind die Schmerzen vom Ausgangsort an einem anderen Ort gewandert?
Nein.
Nein?
Sie sind gleichzeitig im Unterbauch.
Ja.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Sind Sie durch Krampfartige Schmerzen?
Krampfartige Schmerzen, ja.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
1 ist sehr leichter und 10 sehr stark Schmerzen.
So 5 bis 6.
5 bis 6, ja.
Sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Langsam.
Langsam?
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen sie auch wieder weg?
Also ich habe auch Zeit, wo ich keine Schmerzen habe, aber wenn ich diese Durchfälle habe,
vorher und nachher habe ich dann schon ordentliche krampfartige Schmerzen.
Beim Durchfahren krampfartige Schmerzen?
Vorher und nachher.
Ja.
Warten Sie so etwas früher schon einmal?
So lange habe ich durchfahren noch nie gehabt, nein.
Ja, ja.
Bemerken Sie, gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen und diese Beschwerden?
Leider nicht, mir fällt nichts ein.
Ja, wo genau in Leste mal essen?
Wie bitte?
Wo essen, draußen oder zu Hause?
Ich esse fast nie draus, ich esse meist zu Hause.
Zu Hause?
Ja, verstehe ich Sie.
Wann waren Sie letztes Mal im Urlaub?
Letztes Jahr im Sommer.
Entschuldigung.
Haben Sie manchmal Verstopfung und manchmal Durchfall?
Nein, ich habe nur Durchfall.
Keine Verwechslung?
Keine was?
Verwechselung.
Kein Wechsel?
Kein Wechsel, ja.
Haben Sie Blut oder Schleim im Stuhl bemerkt?
Manchmal habe ich auch Bluttonne, ja.
Wie oft gehen Sie zur Toilette?
Ich gehe ungefähr 6-7 Mal am Tag.
Gehen Sie nachts?
Nachts einmal, maximal.
Einmal, ja.
Okay, verstehe ich Sie.
Frau Hoffmann, jetzt gehe ich in den Allgemeinen zu Stand.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ich habe eigentlich guten Appetit.
Gut, ja.
Haben Sie verstärkt eine Durst bemerkt?
Nein.
Haben Sie Husten?
Ich habe keinen Husten, nein.
Keinen Husten?
Haben Sie Luftnot?
Leiden Sie unter Luftnot?
Nein.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Fühlen Sie sich fiebrig?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Auch nicht.
Haben Sie Stärkprost nach Schweiß, Kaltschweiß oder Schweißausbrüte?
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Erbrüche oder Übelkeit?
Gar keine Erbrüche.
Gar keine?
Nur Durchfall.
Wird Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, ich habe noch keine Beschwindigung gehabt.
Ja, okay.
Frau Hoffmann, Entschuldigung, ja.
Haben Sie chronische Krankheiten, an denen Sie leiden?
Ich habe Migräne.
Migräne, ja.
Und andere wichtige Krankheiten?
Nein.
Nur Migräne?
Nur Migräne.
Ja.
Nehmen Sie Medikamente dagegen?
Ich nehme ab und zu Ibuprofen an, ja.
Ibuprofen.
Noch andere Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Nein.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein, noch nie.
Noch nie?
Ja.
Sind Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ich habe nur eine Hausstauballergie.
Ansonsten habe ich keine Allergien.
Unverträglichkeiten sind mir nicht bekannt.
Ja.
Wie äußert sich die Allergie?
Ich habe meistens Niesen und Kaumenjucken.
Ich kann ja verstehen.
Frau Hoffmann, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, wir leben noch.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ja, meine Mutter hat eine Schildbrüllenunterfunktion.
Und mein Vater, der hat erhöhte Cholesterinwerte.
Er nimmt auch ein Medikament dafür.
Ja.
Frau Hoffmann, jetzt komme ich Ihre Gewohnheiten.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich trinke sehr, sehr selten Alkohol.
Ganz selten.
Was trinken Sie? Bier oder Wein?
Cocktail meistens.
Cocktail.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich die nächste Frage.
Frau Hoffmann, haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Ich nehme keine Drogen ein.
Keine?
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Bitte? Ich bin Grafikdesignerin.
Grafikdesignerin.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Ich wohne alleine.
Alleine.
Haben Sie gegen Kinderheit-Krankheiten geimpft?
Ich wurde damals geimpft, ja.
Ich denke, ich bin fertig.
Fragen Sie Sport?
Ja, regelmäßig.
Ich gehe ins Fitnessstudio.
Fitnessstudio, ja.
Frau Hoffmann, ich bin fertig.
Ich denke, das ist die wichtige Frage.
Haben Sie noch Informationen, die wichtig sein könnten?
Also ich habe ein bisschen Angst, weil ich Blut im Stuhl habe.
Meine Oma ist an Darmkrebs verstorben.
Könnte das auch in jedem Fall sein?
Zuerst, das ist so früh, diese
Frage antworten.
Ich werde zuerst körperliche Untersuchungen machen, dann Blut für das Labo abnehmen.
Und danach werde ich ein Optomen-Zonographie-Altraschall machen.
Vielleicht sobald dann alle Befundungen vorliegen, komme ich zu Ihnen und wir beschwören Ihre Situation vielleicht.
Danke.
Darf ich fragen?
Sie haben gesagt Unterbauchschmerzen.
Zeigen Sie mir bitte, wo genau?
Rechtsseitige oder linksseitige?
Beidseitig.
Beidseitig, ok.
Und bitte beschreiben Sie die Kunst Ihren Stuhl.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt Blut, aber sonst noch andere.
Ich habe einen flüssig-schleimigen Stuhl, manchmal mit Blut drin.
Sehen Sie Blas aus?
Nein.
Ok, danke.
Darf ich?
Gibt es etwas, was diese Beschwerden verstärkt oder verlinkt?
Nein.
Ich komme und gehe.
Ok, haben Sie Stress?
Ich bin in der Privatleibung oder in der Arbeit.
Ja, habe ich.
Danke.
Frau Hoffmann, ist Ihnen über den Riechen des Stuhls aufgefallen?
Nein.
Oder klebrig?
Nein?
Danke.
Gibt es eine Beschwerde in Ihrer Familie?
Heißt du, dass meine Oma Dampfkrebs hat?
Wie alt war sie?
Sie war 70.
Und wie ist Ihre geneokologische Situation? Wann war Ihre letzte Regeldurche?
Die war vor Kurzem erst.
Da habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme.
Ist das möglich, dass Sie gerade schwanger sind?
Nein, das kann ich ausschließen.
Wann war Ihre letzte Frauenarztbesuch?
Das war vor drei Monaten ungefähr.
War das alles in Ordnung?
Da war alles in Ordnung.
Danke.
Ich habe diese Beschwerden aber auch noch nicht.
Sie sind später erst gekommen.
Frau Hoffmann, sind Ihnen Gelenkschmerzen aufgefallen?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen Gelenkschmerzen tatsächlich.
An den Handgelenken habe ich Schmerzen.
Manchmal auch an den Fußgelenken.
Das ist mir auch neu aufgefallen jetzt.
Ich dachte, es kommt zuerst vom Sport.
Aber auch wenn ich keinen Sport mache, habe ich diese Beschwerden.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie nehmen Ibuprofen.
Welche Milligramm und wie viel Mal pro Tag?
Ich nehme das nicht so oft ein.
Ich nehme 600 Milligramm ein, wenn ich meine Migräne habe.
Frau Hoffmann, haben Sie auch Morgensteifigkeit?
Nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Leiden Sie unter Sehstörungen?
Nein, würde ich nicht sagen.
Sind Sie soweit fertig?
Guten Tag Herr Oberas.
Bitte schön, hallo.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin.
Wenn Sie Zeit haben, möchte ich Ihnen den Fall kurz vorstellen.
Darf ich?
Ja, ich bitte darum.
Die Patientin heißt Claudia Hoffmann.
Sie ist 34 Jahre alt.
Sie ist 60 Kilogramm schwer und ist 60 Cent.
Frau Claudia Hoffmann stellte sich heute bei uns wegen
seit zwei Monaten bestehender, langsam aufgetretener,
beidseitiger Unterbauchschmerzen vor.
Die Patientin beschreibt die Schmerzen als
krampfartig. Die Schmerzen sind intensiv bei 5 bis 6 von 10 auf der Skala.
Die Schmerzen seien beim Durchfall aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzen stören keine andere Körperregion und keine andere Körperregion.
Zudem erwarten die Patienten früher keine ähnlichen Beschwerden aufgetreten.
Die Beschwerden würden nicht ähnlichen.
Die vegetative Anamnese ist vor und ist auf ähnlichen Widen.
Die Schmerzen würden mit 5 Kilogramm innerhalb von zwei Monaten Gewicht abnehmen.
Die vegetative Anamnese war bis auf... bis auffällig...
Entschuldigung, unauffällig.
Die Anfallerkrankungen nannten sie eine Migraine.
Dagegen nehmen sie 600 Milligramm Illuprofen bei Bedarf.
Sie hat keine OP und Unfallanamnese.
Besonders bei Allergien gab es eine Hochschnupfen und Annen, die sich durch Niesen und Kauumenjücken äußern.
Hochschnupfen oder?
Hochschnupfen, ja.
In Bezug auf die Familienanamnese gab es die Anamnese, dass der Vater an Hyperlipidemie und die Mutter an Hypothyroese leidet.
Und auch die Mutter hat Darmkrebs.
Der Patient leidet an Darmkrebs.
Die Mutter oder die Großmutter?
Ich verstehe die Mutter, aber sie ist Großmutter.
Großmutter.
Der Patient ist nicht Raucherin und trinkt gelegentlich Cocktail.
Drogenkonsum würde verneint.
Die Patientin ist ein Grafikdesigner und sie ist leidlich.
Sie wohnt alleine, hat keine Kinder.
Sie ist gegen Kinderkrankheiten vollgeimpft.
Aufgrund der Anamnestischen Angaben gehe ich von einem Verdacht auf eine chronisch entzündliche Darmentzündung.
Zum Beispiel Polythys ulcerosa oder Morbus Crohn aus.
Hätten die Durchfälle Schubfall?
Sie hat uns gesagt, es ist Schubfall, weil die Abdominalschmerzen beim Durchfall treten und gehen sie wieder weg.
Ich verstehe das.
Schubfallartige.
Differenzierte Diagnostik kommen.
Darmkrebs vielleicht oder Gastroenteritis in Betracht.
Zunächst werde ich die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine gründliche, körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei einer körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf an, Abwärtsspannung, Druckschmerz, Loslassschmerz.
Und ich werde den Patienten Blut abnehmen.
Blutbild, CRP, BSG, Elektrolyte, Liba und Nierenwerte.
Und ich erinnere mich an die anderen entzündlichen Parameter.
CRP und Prokrastonin.
Ja, Prokrastonin.
Des Weiteren plane ich eine Abdominalschmerz.
Und gegebenenfalls werde ich eine Koloskopie planen.
Waren Sie noch vor, wenn Sie die Patienten stationär aufnehmen?
Ja, ja.
Versuchung halten Sie da ein?
Ja, ja. Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Und dann würde ich die Patienten in zwei Böden anpflegen und eine analytische Flüssigkeit einleiten.
Das meine ich nicht. Das ist schon Therapie.
Ich meine Diagnostik.
Können Sie noch etwas Wichtiges machen?
Ja.
Labor, Labor ist richtig, Labor Blut?
Noch was?
Labor, die wichtigste. Die erste ist die körperliche Untersuchung.
Ja, die zweite Blutbild, wir haben gesagt. Und die dritte ist vielleicht bildgebende Verfahren.
Stuhlprobe ist auch wichtig. Stuhlprobe.
Entschuldigung.
Stuhlprobe.
Wenn Sie den Verdacht noch einer CID haben, Koloskopie, körperliche Darmerkrankung,
sollten Sie auf jeden Fall eine Stuhlprobe, wie zum Beispiel Kaltprotektin, ist der Marker bei Entzündungen da.
Ja.
Die zweite ist Optomansono, dann gegebenenfalls Koloskopie.
Machen Sie eine Koloskopie, wenn sie auch eine Entzündung hat oder warten Sie erst ab?
Ja, ja. Wir müssen warten, nachdem wir die Parameter nachlassen. Wir werden Koloskopie durchführen.
Was denken Sie? Ist es eher eine Kolizulzerose oder ein Moduskoloskopie?
Ja, sie hat gesagt, ein Gelenkschmerzen und die anderen Parameter. Ich erinnere mich nicht, aber vielleicht Kolizulzerose.
Ja, genau. Gelenkschmerzen, blutige Stühle. Bei Korn haben Sie selten blutige Stühle.
Ja, bei Korn. Sehr gut gemacht. Gibt es Fragen? Gibt es Ergänzungen? Ich denke, die Patientin hat eine chronisch-oserose.
Darf ich fragen, sind wir sicher, um die Entzündungsparameter Linden danach Koloskopie durchführen?
Oder können wir sofort Koloskopie machen und dann die Diagnose stellen und unsere Therapie schildern?
Ja, also die Sache ist ja folgendes. Wenn sie jetzt eine sehr starke Blutung hat und sehr starke entzündungsruhe Entzündungszeichen,
dann würde man vielleicht erst mal ein bisschen abwarten, bis die Entzündungswerte fallen. Gegebenenfalls CT machen, Ultraschall machen vorher.
Und wenn die Entzündung abgefallen ist, kann man die Darmspielung machen. Aber Sie haben recht.
Man muss zeitnah eine Darmspielung machen, damit wir wissen, worum es geht und wir helfen können.
Weil man muss ja gucken, wir hatten das jetzt schon seit drei Monaten, zwei Monaten.
Und dann müssen wir gucken, dass wir mit Mesalazin oder mit Cortison arbeiten können.
Entzündung, wir warten mit Morbus Crohn, häufig extra intestinales Symptome.
Wie bitte?
Extra intestinales Symptome ist häufig Morbus Crohn.
Was ist häufig? Ich habe das nicht verstanden. Entschuldigung.
Ja, extra intestinales Symptome.
Ja, richtig.
Aber die Colitis Ulcerosa geht meistens mit Gelenzschmerzen und blutigen Stühlen einher.
Der Crohn meistens nicht.
Ok, danke.
Und in der Regel, Sie wissen ja, Morbus Crohn kann alles befallen, von Mund bis zum Anus.
Aber Colitis Ulcerosa befehlt nur den Da.
Das bedeutet, während der richtige Koloskopie, wir werden nur Substitution, Flüssigkeit, gegebenenfalls Elektrositübergabe.
Ja, symptomatische Therapie machen, ganz genau.
Ok, danke.
Erstmal. Und dann guckt man, dass man aber zeitnah eine Koloskopie machen sollte, damit wir wissen, wie der Da von innen aussieht.
Hier, natürlich, könnt ihr die Lokalisation von dem Da besser wissen.
Wahrscheinlich in der Anus- oder Rektum-Bereiche.
Aber wenn es in der Gleise ist, dann kann es in einer höheren Bedeutung sein.
Hose, können Sie die Formulierungen wiederholen? Ich habe die Schreibung wieder aufgeschrieben.
Es ist frisches Blut, helft, ist es nicht, wenn es nicht ist.
Ist es frisches Blut, hellrotes Blut, aufgelagertes Blut, ein Blutstreifen auf dem Stuhlgang, oder ist es vermischtes Blut mit dem Stuhlgang?
Hier, hier ist die Samma.
Wer hier, der Nöges, der Faktor, der Untermutung, mag er nicht.